welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
I'm your host Jared aka the poison
mushroom version of the guy who usually
does this and in this video we're going
to be going over the ending of the Super
Mario Bros movie Yahoo this movie is is
currently collecting all of the gold
coins and in this breakdown we're going
to be going over the plot the couple
ending credit scenes are theories on
potential sequels along with our
thoughts of the movie be prepared
because heavy spoilers are warp pipe
into ya so if you haven't had a chance
to watch it then I highly recommend you
backwards long jump out of here please
ground pound that thumbs up and also
make sure to subscribe for daily
breakdowns with that out of the way
thank you for clicking this again I am
Jared let's pickle
we
go
alright so the Super Mario Bros quickly
opens with Bowser wreaking havoc on the
Penguin's ice kingdom easily stomping
them out smashing a glowing question
block to reveal a superstar this scene
was actually already released as we
triple jump over to Mario and Luigi now
in Brooklyn none of that new donk city
folks as they deal with their struggling
Plumbing business the pair left steady
jobs with the Wrecking Crew yes the same
1985 Wrecking Crew form and Spike even
makes an appearance on the evening news
though the pair sees a crucial water
main leak downtown and the two head out
to drain some pipes however upon
searching for the source of the leak the
Mario Bros discover abandoned pipes one
of which is your iconic green warp pipe
as the two are sucked in one by one this
sequence kind of looked like the
universe jumping from the across the
spider-verse trailer as Mario lands in
the mush Mushroom Kingdom the home of
Princess Peach while Luigi is spit out
in the dark lands AKA Bowser's Kingdom
Luigi is captured by a terrifying group
of dry bones and suspended above
Bowser's lava pits with the rest of his
captives the penguins from earlier and
the lumalir Aluma from the Mario Galaxy
series Mario on the other hand is guided
to Peach's castle by Toad and introduced
to her as she's Amazed by the sight of
another human with word of Bowser being
in possession of the Superstar Peach is
terrified because Bowser is coming yeah
it's quite the sticky situation because
he wants to forcibly marry her similar
to the Mario Odyssey storyline Peach
attempts to train Mario in a Nostalgia
filled obstacle course backed by Bonnie
Tyler's Holding Out for a Hero and this
scene the music everything slaps here
but they need more help obviously
seeking the alliance of the Kongs from
Jungle Kingdom the only way they will
team up is if Mario goes head to head
with Donkey Kong in a Thor versus
hulk-like Ragnarok Arena Battle and wins
a rivalry 41 years in the making uh
because you know the Donkey Kong arcade
cabinet the infamous DK rap is Donkey
Kong's intro song
Mario of course gets his cheeks clapped
like the DK Jungle Beat Bongos but
luckily finds his footing obtaining the
super Bell Cat Mario power up meow this
is perfect with him defeating DK the DK
and mushroom Crews roll out in a Mad Max
Fury road-like go-kart formation Rainbow
Road AC DC's Thunderstruck is playing
this scene this scene is straight up
fire but everyone is ambushed by the
Koopa Clan Mario and DK fall into the
ocean swallowed by that pesky eel from
Mario 64. I still don't like that dude
after all these years Peach and Toad
though race off to warn the rest of
Mushroom Kingdom as all of the Kongs are
captured joining Luigi over The Lava
Pits I mean the Luigi you're done dirty
throughout this whole movie Peach
begrudgingly accepts Bowser's wedding
proposal again very Mario odyssey-esque
luckily DK and Mario escaped the pesky
eel with with a DK rocket Barrel
straight up Vince Vaughn and Owen Wilson
crash in the wedding Wow saving all of
the prisoners from being sacrificed
Peach busts out an ice flower power up
freezing most of the Koopas but Bowser
unleashes a bonsai Bill to destroy all
of the Mushroom Kingdom Mario Thinking
Fast grabs the raccoon or Tanuki
power-up diverting the Bonsai build to
the same warp pipe that connects
Brooklyn to the Mushroom Kingdom and
explodes this causes the worlds to blend
bringing them back to Brooklyn now Mario
is about to be singed by Bowser's fire
breath but Luigi steps in and the pair
activate the Superstar together full-on
star power mode with the music and
everything as the two defeat hordes of
koopa's besting Bowser and shrinking him
down with a poisonous mushroom capturing
him in a jar Brooklyn in the Mushroom
Kingdom are saved by the yo Mario Bros
as we see see them then thriving in
their new life as residents of the
Mushroom Kingdom rather than that of
Brooklyn
Super Mario Bros now don't get up and
leave the Mario goodness just yet
because there are both a mid and
post-credits scenes to wet that Mario
appetite for the mid credits we get
another soft piano ballad with the
boisterous Talent of Jack Black's Bowser
serenading his dear old peachy he still
has a longing for the princess but a
toad quickly Cuts him off as its
revealed Bowser is still stunted by the
poisonous mushroom that ended the movie
and trapped in a tiny cage in the
Mushroom Kingdom it's a nice Final Touch
of that Tenacious D stylings and I guess
just lets us know as viewers Bowser is
currently iced he's trapped but still
has motive for peach the post-credits
scene on the other hand teases at a
potential sequel as the camera weaves
through the elaborate Maze of pipes
underground of Brooklyn New York where
Mario and Luigi originally were sucked
up not not sucked off they were sucked
into the mud so wow they were sucked
into the Mushroom Kingdom via the green
warp pipe here though we see a familiar
white and green spotted egg amongst some
of the leftover rubble from Bowser's
Invasion the camera slowly moves in as
the egg begins to crack and hatch as the
screen cuts to Black and we hear the
iconic iconic Sound Of The Lovable
lizard
I guess for anyone who may not know this
dinosaur-like companion first appeared
in 1990s Super Mario World big long Tong
eats things poops out eggs he's appeared
in his own games and been a series
staple sense despite Mario constantly
disrespecting him anyway this egg was
originally a gift at Bowser and Peach's
wedding and seems all Yoshi my dude will
be showing up for the potential sequel
speaking of a sequel with early reports
projecting Super Mario Bros opening
weekend to be somewhere around
225 million dollars Yahoo
that's a lot of gold coins so you know a
sequel is gonna happen hell multiple
sequels and spin-offs are bound to be
cooking over at Nintendo and
illumination of course with Yoshi being
the final tease a sequel will most
likely involve him potentially expanding
on the Super Mario worlds over to
Yoshi's Island and seeing the bond
between Mario and Yoshi further develop
there were even multiple shots of other
environments beyond that of the Mushroom
Kingdom so there's still a lot to
explore in this world and uh is very
promising as to like what we could
expect over the next 10 years like an
entire universe of these types of movies
they're super nostalgic they're really
fun it's illumination so they know what
they're doing but beyond the Yoshi teas
the film leaves little mushroom Clues as
to what other sequels could entail for
example it's mentioned Princess Peach as
a baby just warp piped into the Mushroom
Kingdom one day with her Origins being
unknown an explorative journey to find
her parents or family could be a plot
beat in the sequel therefore introducing
Daisy or Princess Daisy into this world
the two are often portrayed as besties
while a couple of unofficial Mario Kart
Double Dash and Mario Kart Wii guides
even stated that the pair are cousins
again unofficially Nintendo has yet to
confirm this but again this could add
another element to the Super Mario
cinematic World Rosalina and Mario
Galaxy could be another way that they
take things solely because Princess
Peach brings up the fact that there are
multiple galaxies out there while
looking up into the night sky Luma Lee I
think I pronounced that incorrectly
before but the lovable psychopath who
ends the movie also shows up in both the
Mario Galaxy games and is technically a
Luma star of which Rosalina is their
adoptive mother so you know the Mario
Bros writers are cooking up something
yes we need to go to space lastly Luigi
was left out of the spotlight through a
lot of this always in his brother's
Shadow so for me you your grandma
everyone included including Charlie Day
wants a Luigi's Mansion movie you know
but there's been talk of Luigi's Mansion
for that was a GameCube I think that
would be great Haunted Mansion
Ghostbuster influences in the Mario
Style and it's a go but uh yeah let me
know what Mario story you'd want to see
adapted for a sequel in the comments
personally I'd like to see a weird Alice
in Wonderland adaptation of Super Mario
64 jumping into paintings the whole
thing let's get weird with it but yeah I
really had a blast watching the Super
Mario Bros movie sure it was just me
alone at 10 am showing with nothing but
parents and their kids but everyone was
enjoying it I had a blast again it was
great it was the power of Mario over
generations and dozens of games that
offered so much cleverly placed fan
service but this was this was good fan
service because like the amount of small
obscure Easter eggs hidden in the
background and even musical cues of
certain scenes was so appreciated the
all-around attention to detail was
beyond what I could have asked for in a
Mario movie but the real MVP carrying
the entire movie was the music classic
theme newer themes small musical cues
like
of world one two obscure beloved songs
like the DK rap from Donkey Kong 64 and
even newer songs for the movie provided
by Jack Black's Bowser this is the Super
Mario Brothers theme
the movie is hitting on all cylinders
hell the couple of Mario Kart Montage
bits were some of the coolest scenes of
the movie The Rainbow Road shortcut
Easter egg spoke to my 10 year old N64
loving heart Mario and Luigi's big
screen outing deserves a solid 8.5 out
of 10 a great first review for their
hopeful thriving Brooklyn and Mushroom
Kingdom Plumbing businesses two small
bugaboos though that caused it not to be
that perfect grab of the flag finish
some of the voice cast mainly being
Mario Chris Pratt is a distraction from
the fun again after the first 10 minutes
it all kind of Blends together but my
man his Mamma Mia's needed more Gusto
while the story in general feels far too
rushed almost implied like these
characters already have Rapport or if
they're in a sticky situation it solved
like 30 seconds later again minor
problems but yeah this this was awesome
here we go
oh but please put Mario in that damn
Frog costume for a sequel I'm begging
you anyway I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the Super Mario Bros movie
was this the perfect Redemption from the
questionable 1993 Mario movie and what
were some of your favorite Mario or
Nintendo Easter eggs just hidden in
there and I'll let you know we're
currently running a competition giving
away three copies of the Superman
collection on the 15th of April and all
you gotta do to get a chance of winning
this is like this video make sure to
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below on your thoughts of the
Mario movie we picked the comments at
random at the end of every single month
and the winners of last month are on
screen right now so if that's you
message us on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch be
sure to check out some of our other cool
videos right over there yellow jackets
John Wick I don't even know it's
everything but thank you for your
constant support I've been Jared Mario
movie this is a great movie go check it
out I'll see you in the next one take
care and let's go cool